we think that the the the major hurdle
or the the first hoop to jump through
is making people
sure enough or trusty enough in order to
get up in the air
and for that to happen they need to have
assurance that the instrument will take
care of most problems
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opwest hello stanford leap and
birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders today we're
going to be talking about air literally
air
meet ronnie plowed the ceo and
co-founder of air the startup
reimagining air mobility with ev tolls
for mass personal use with the rich
background mathematics and physics
automotive and aerospace technologies
ronnie's impressive experience has led
him to work with several oems and serve
on the boards of multiple tech companies
and venture funds
prior to co-founding air he was ceo and
co-founder of bmax a leading provider of
advanced metal processing solutions
ronnie plout welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you
happy to be here happy to be here
thank you very much i am very happy that
you're here because and this is yet
another one of those episodes where i
get to dive into this whole new domain
that is just fascinating for anybody
walking this planet which is the the air
above us and mobility and the future of
air mobility uh we are the co-founder
and ceo of air a a relatively new
company working on in this space and so
before we even talk about you know air
mobility in my air just give me a in you
know a few sentences a little bit about
your own background and what led you to
to be so fascinated and enticed by this
idea of air mobility
sure
um so my background is physics and
mathematics
i never graduated actually i did two
years in university
when i was very very young
and
all my life i have been working with
tangible things so i know a lot about
their eye and computer vision but my
passion is with tangible things physics
materials things that move mechanics and
so forth that's the passion and frankly
uh i think that air mobility is the
future uh you know as evs were 10 years
ago i think it's it's about
air ev's now and uh i think uh you know
um the slogan that i coined in the
company and all of our presentations
is everybody wants to fly which which is
not about flying as a pilot
but flying really flying so peter pan
flying
falcore flying
being in the air
leonardo da vinci's thought about it
everybody thinks about it
i think it's natural
so tell me a little bit about you know
where we're at today in terms of the air
above us in terms of you know people or
organizations thinking about air
mobility is actually
a potential source of mobility for the
future
um so so first of all i think that again
the the if you if you look at what's
happening now in mobility in general
um so it's crowded congestion is a
problem that everybody faces on a daily
basis
and it's very it's very clear that we
have to find
different solutions or i would say
additional solutions because people will
keep moving uh kovit makes the made us
uh
move less
and we learn how to move less but i
think that it shows that generally
people are going to move and keep moving
for the for for the rest of humanity's
future
and we have to find ways to do it better
and since teleportation is not an option
yet
uh we have to find other other means in
other ways and the only other means and
ways is to go
up and down okay so you have the boring
company of uh you know going so
underground and and and the rest is
there i mean and by the way air is i
mean you have a lot of it
uh volume is by definition greater than
than area
so two-dimensional and three-dimensional
are very very different and i think it's
very very clear that we're going to go
into the third dimension mobility by
definition
in general uh as the as humanity goes to
sustainable energy uh it has to go hand
in hand there is no point in burning
fossil fuels over air mobility so now
the problem is how do we do it without
burning fossil fuel and of course the
immediate answer is electricity
um and then um
this is the way this is the
place by the way where
me myself as a as an entrepreneur and us
as a company heir
we think about it is a little bit
differently than other people in the
industry
uh regarding the approach to
how how to address the point of change
from ground mobility to air mobility
um okay and uh yeah
sorry now why is now you know the so you
know you're mentioning leonardo da vinci
you're mentioning all these
thinkers that for hundreds of years have
realized that this is you know where
we're headed but but why is now the
right time to build a technology and
physical product startup in this space
why why now why not five years ago why
not in five years right because we
always we always think of timing as a
core component of a startup success and
and and you you've decided that now is
the right time to do this
yeah so first of all uh we have started
four years ago and i think a lot of
people have started even earlier uh it's
not not necessarily exactly now but it's
it's within the past five years i would
say and there are a few reasons for that
i think the key reason is the there is
an inflection point where you come to a
place where enough technologies
are commoditized in a in a practical way
to be used
um
so if you take uh and again i'm not
comparing apple to air to apple um but
but if you look at the iphone
uh there is no technological invention
there right it's only pure integration
of very very advanced technologies
so touch screens has been around for for
years
uh
application i mean the computing power
was converging but there is a point
where enough of the technologies are
matured enough
and and integratable enough
in order to create something which is an
inflection point or a tectonic change
um i think that the same happens now in
air mobility if you look at things that
fly
uh you know people have been flying
since
1903 right the wright brothers uh so
physically it's possible uh but a lot of
things advanced so material science uh
production technologies and i think that
the inflection point happened
in recent years because of a few
industries one of them for example is
drones
if you look at drone technology a drone
was something that you used to buy
for your child 10 years ago and it used
to fly for
six seconds or one minute until it
crashed completely
uh
and and your boy ended up crying right
the dgi's of today
they don't crash and they don't crash
because
flight control and the algorithms and
the imus in those systems because became
so
so robust
that they don't fall out of the sky out
of the sky right it's it's robust enough
for people to use in a manner which is
very very stable
and we are talking again about software
hardware
sensors a lot of things became to be
matured enough to support those
industries in order to be
used by
people right now tell me a little bit
about about
where you're at today you know
over a few years working on this and
what is sort of the vision of this
company
so as i said um we think that uh uh
we think a little bit differently about
this uh this space
uh generally speaking we started four
years ago we have started the company
was initiated by uh ken rosen who is the
the founder of the company and he uh he
is a guy that flies things around for
for decades
uh and he's very very passionate about
it and uh basically he started building
things so until now we have see we have
built six substantial prototypes up to
full scale
um i can show it to you if you like by
the way of course um and 100 yes so
yeah so take me with you this is our
yeah so this is our shop floor uh
we have uh
large things okay so this is like a
prototype of cockpit
okay
so and what you can also see here
we are playing with very very large toys
so we have prototypes which are
uh this is a i mean a real real size
airplane as you can see
wow it's the coolest toy
the coolest toy a guy can have right so
we have been flying those large things
based on a very very unique and patented
aerodynamic topology
combined with a very unique and
proprietary flight control system both
hardware and software to enable what we
call personal air mobility
and i said that we are different from
others in the in the field and this is
basically about the fact that we believe
that it's more about the people the user
rather than the technology
uh
so you know when you go to buy
a car
um
you know the dealer doesn't say okay
i'll show you that it goes on the road
you assume it goes on the road right
and i think that people think tend to
think that we are
used to being in the air okay because we
fly airbus 380s
uh but but you are very isolated from
the experience right right so you're 10
kilometers up in the sky 30 000 feet
uh but actually you don't feel that
right the only people that feel
the flight
are
aviators okay so these are like savvy
hobbyists that are taking their cessnas
and their
micro micro airplanes and they can
really feel it
i think and there are not so many people
okay so most of the people are not used
to
gliding okay so have real interaction
with with the air this is why we called
ourselves air by the way
we think that the the the major hurdle
or the the first hoop to jump through
is making people
sure enough or trusty enough in order to
get up in the air
and for that to happen they need to have
assurance that the instrument will take
care of most problems okay because a
pilot is a very professional
uh
operator i would say okay so when you're
driving a car you know you can be
a grandmother an 82 grandmother from
tennessee
you know and she's a driver right
uh being a pilot is a very professional
there is a very professional aroma okay
or or a halo
right and we are trying to remove this
halo
we're trying to create a vehicle
which is which is about you taking it up
in the sky and feeling uh trustworthy
enough
uh to be safe
okay and that's the whole essence of air
this is why we're playing with those
large things
we have a very cool design we're
designing the aircraft on automotive
based technologies and techniques
i cannot show you the design i can show
you a silhouette we're going to release
it within about a month um but i can
assure you it's the coolest thing you've
ever seen
incredible incredible it doesn't look
like an airplane yeah i i love it now i
love that you mentioned that the biggest
hurdle to this
or one of the biggest hurdles of this is
the consumer
behavior shift and
and feeling safe and having trust in
this new behavior that they're going to
have to to be a part of but you know
when i'm thinking of the company such as
air and what it would take for a product
like this to reach market i'm thinking
of many more hurdles whether it be
governmental assurances you know flight
controls stuff like that uh
how how big of a part do those play in
your road map and your strategic
thinking of building this out
uh
so
if if you map it out
there aren't so many hurdles okay um
and uh as as you know uh i don't
remember who said it but in most cases
time takes care of most things
okay i remember that i remember a
lecture that somebody said that
in the 1980s people said that the
personal computer won't come about
because people don't know how to type
interesting and uh i don't remember who
said it but he i remember him saying
that death will take care of that
okay
because
um
the government the government yeah so
the government is is is
very uh i can say that even the israeli
government and for sure the the u.s
government and also in europe they look
at the market okay and if the market
wants things to fly
regulation takes care of it uh you can
see we are working closely for example
with the faa and i can tell you that
they are very open it's not that they're
very easy okay they don't they don't
just say go fly
uh but they have we have a very open and
constructive conversation with them
there are some emerging uh certification
basis
uh you can see jobby jobby is flying
around with uh of course it's it's still
under experimental level uh but there is
an experiment there is a certification
basis for those things to fly it will
take some time for those things to fly
over people okay
but for example if you go to uh sport
aviation
sport aviation is relevant for areas g
and e in the us which is 95 of the area
okay so
okay excluding cities excluding airports
right
okay it's up there in the air
that makes a lot of sense now tell me
what what happens you know
five ten years down the line how do you
envision air as a part of this new world
that we live in is this something that
every that people will have in their
backyard just like they have a tesla
they'll have a one of your one one of
your mobility a products uh is this is
this for the average consumer is this
going to be something that you know in a
dozen years most people will have how do
you envision this
we are building the things that from
inception to
volume production and at volume
production we're aiming as low as
possible
uh again
in in this sense the volume is not
automotive volume okay so
a race car sells for 10 000 units per
year okay if you go to the commodities
like the golf volkswagen golf or
or or prius you're talking about
hundreds of thousands or up to a million
a year right per model we think that we
can go up to tens of thousands of units
per year in the u.s at home
and again if you look at the size of the
population
and you're talking about rule the
connection between rural areas and urban
areas right we think that
that many many many thousands of units
per year sold is something which is
completely conceivable again if it's
affordable easy to handle and easy to
certify
i love it i think that i think this is
so fascinating i'd love to get to know
you a little bit better and and through
that also understand a little bit more
about you know your role within now air
and what you're doing there perhaps take
me back a little bit to your childhood
and what what really fascinates you as a
kid is it always
something around mobility consumer
behavior is this a trend or or were you
curious about other things
um well i was a weird kid i must say i
was i i was and i still am a physicist
and an artist so i paint and i i do
sculpturing
but i also do
high power physics
uh and i think there is a lot in the
combination of art and sciences right um
there is a division between
a physicist and a mathematician i'm more
of the mortal former i'm a physicist
before i'm a mathematician but i always
look for the beauty of things
and in general i look for equilibriums
okay so i look for places where i can
bring something to to a very uh
stable situation and flight actually is
one of those things
uh uh again for example high speed
anything that moves in high speed
needs to be very very robust and stable
and balanced this is my passion it
sounds maybe weird but uh
a good painting and a good physics
equation is is for me is the same right
i i love it and if you look at your
day-to-day now
and what where do you really draw your
own inspiration from whether it's
professionally personally with thin air
outside of it
um
i try to i try to have as little regrets
as possible
uh that's the first principle
uh and the second principle is is uh
is bringing things to the right position
it's very different from perfectionism
uh there is
the right spot okay so being perfect
often comes on on on
you take from one place in order to
perfect
uh i i think that perfectionism for the
sake of perfectionism is wrong
uh it's better to look at the system and
i'm trying to get as i said to a
balanced situation which is the right
level of compromises in order to get to
a very very
uh to the right position i'm trying very
hard not to say the perfect
the perfect situation or the perfect
solution but at the end it is perfect
it's perfect as a solution
so each part of the equation is not the
perfect solution for the
for the mini problem but at the macro
level you have a very very perfect
solution this is what we're trying to
get with the air so it's a it's a
vehicle for example that would be not
the best in aerodynamics not the best in
terms of uh uh
range versus uh range to power or weight
ratio but would it would be perfect for
the user so it's more important to be
usable
and easy and easy to handle rather to be
for example long in range we're going to
have 100 miles range
we can do more
but but this will be on in in the
expense of the of the user right okay so
we're trying to get to to the right spot
i love it and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
um i would say physicist artist
and uh
probably a juggler
yeah i love it it's about holding all
balls in the air yeah i love it i love
it honey thank you very very much best
of luck with all right i can't wait to
hopefully have one of these one of these
uh
cars planes something in between uh in
my own backyard and uh and i think that
obviously this is the future and i'm i'm
i'm excited to look back on this
conversation in a few years and so thank
you very very much for the time and the
inspiration and best of luck thank you
thank you thank you very much thank you